>>> TO ME THE STOUT AI THIS WEE
PRESIDENG AN
ORTOURTAIL I THEG ON CAPITOL HIH
AND MARKTR UTILIZED TO FINISH IY
NERSBOUT HOW MALE
STUDENTSWESTFIELD HIAR NUDE
PHOTOGRAPHS OF THEIR FW
FEMALE SNTM  PHOTOS USING AI.
THERE ARE ENT WILLFEDERAL LAN
CREATSHARING NODEEPRNOGRAA  F F
FR0102D % ARE THS
SEXU ED FEATUR
WOME TO THE
VIDEOS.
IWESTFIELD TOOK
PLACE OVER TUMMER, BUT
OFFIALUT
ON OCTOBER0th.
IMPLENT
D  OUT AN EMA PARER GUARDIAN THD
AFFECTED BY IT TO CALL THE LOCAL
POLICEHEGIVABL
YO TRANSGRESSION.
THOL SAID WE'RAB
TO PROVIDE SCIC DETAILON
IMD  MATTERS ARE DEP
CHAL.
ONE OF THOSE S
14-YEAR-OLD HE
MOTHER
FRAN FOR BEING
HERE.
SORRY THIS HAPPE YOU.LE IT?
PIECE THAT SAID ONR CHOOL THE BO
NO GL S HAPPEN KNEE BOYS KNE,
SOMETHIN
AND THNE WASAL
DOE PRINCIPALSE TO
BE CONFIRMED A
STUDENTSTHE AI INCID LIE, AFTEL.
AS I WASALKING THE HALLWAYS, IG
CRYING. OFIR
THAT'S WHEN I REIZ
E AND TOLD MMOM, WE SHOULD DO S
AND >>T MEF
I DON'T THINYON TH
IM
YESS KNOW HOW
MANYERRLVICTIMIZ A DO YOKNOWHO
S SIBLE?
KWHWAS RED THATE ARE OVER 34 G
INVOLVEDTHIS.
DAI GOING TO
SOCREEN FROM"THE WALL STETECE O
AMONNTS, THERERCUSSIONEEMEFUL NL
HOW DO YOU SEE IT,AROA?
AND OVERL BE B OVER
GIRLS WIE RLS.
AN IEG.IAID RIGHT
INS SITUATION,
THWEE BOYSR BOY -- AT T, YOU ,
WITHOUT CONS G
INAPPROPRIATE IMESHE SAME TIME S
FROM
TR TO SAYYS WHO REACHED O
THIS INOT OKAY.EYOU?
WE FEEWHAT CANE DOMAHES WILL BEG
D
>>, DO YOU THI
TH IK THL LAENFO
CONTRIBUTEO HELPING MAKE ALL
E GIRLS MO COMFORTABLEO MANY GI
AND I ALSO THINKA LAW INPUTTED
T EVERYONE FROM
>> SESCA, IF YOU KNOW
S RESPONSIBLE, IME OTHERS  SCHO
FAR ASOU KNOW SO NOT REALLY.
NONO. ASREN ANY
COMMUNICATION AMONTHING OF THE ,
ATUATION MAY O
BSOLUTELMULTIPLE OF MOTHERS REA.
'SIS THEM, SI ENED TO THEM.HO WH
I HAD NO WITH THE OTHER
SIDE.E.
THE PRINCIPAL TO ME.
ER.
THE W LEADEF OSPAAPOLOGIZED TO?
>> N HMM.AT WOULD YOUIF
IUL A'THINKI DOT  R WID.
>> RIGHT.
NDEFENE
>> YES.
SOMETHING.W, II MAY ADD
M SO PROUD OF
ADVOCATING FOR HERSELF AND
THE OTHER RL
ME TOTH IR NEW JERSEY
SO THEY'REING SUHATEVER  RIGHTEL
BED THISBER, MAKREEY CHIN E SAF
R CHILDREN.
K THIS ISSUE IMORE CO JUST STFIH
SC,  IITTOT AS A
TEACHABLE AT S
>> FRANCESCA, GOODK TO.
THANK YOU, DOROTA.
>>> CHN,, WHAT
DOG
MINDS ANLENT
>> I MEAN IT'S TOO PREVALENT.ITI